é é uma atitude pessoal aqui quem fala é
o lugar que seja muito em mim já mais de
um filho dele e hoje acho que vou
cometer o maior erro da minha vida que é
jogar fight night at freddy's nos jogos
livro
agora temos aqui dentro do fat freddy's
que na verdade é um ano night at
freddy's 3d e isso não é um jogo
original é tipo um fã mas para óculos
livre isto tá brutal pessoal eo fred
baby doc como é que comece isto temos
várias dificuldades temos juízes e o
normal
miriam guarda e ultra outra - não eu vou
pro normal se calhar não eu vou pra mim
mesmo não atendeu ou não vamos começar
vamos cruz aristocrata show jogo por
favor não pode afastar alguém não parece
mesmo que estou querendo meu que eu
tenho que fazer com que você está tudo
escuro à caraças que a transmil não
consiga nada que diga não vamos sair
daqui ok isto tá muito real - está mesmo
à minha frente está muito pior para
escuto que centavo que o que reluz o
gordo não digam que eu vou perceber que
não se usa por seringa néné e deboni não
está muito real só voz e experimentei
esta [ __ ] - ele está muito real eu
percebi estava aqui eu não vou abrir a
porta é que nem pensar é que nem pensar
meu corpo eu só tô aqui e vou estar
voltados para marceneiro luz
a propósito a criação embora vão embora
apaga a luz ok
a proposta agora na questão é conseguir
ter um filho pra quem supostamente acho
que o chico não chega não se não já vem
para aqui pra isso saleh
acho que é sempre pela direita e também
o gave na história tem muito medo meu
porque eu vi jogar este jubileu andam as
câmeras não não quer passar as suas
portas fechem as portas não quer saber
não quer saber fechar as portas
o toque entre mim e não consegui nada
atrás de mim está tudo escuro que traz
nenhum gosto e não gosto do tejo tudo
escuro atrás de mim
além do talento não olha o freddy guarín
aqui aqui postou recolhe casa junto não
não os querem minhoco meu todos virem
pra cima me como é que é possível
novidade
não não me choca com este jogo mas que
isso não constitui nenhum eu tenho
trocado cueca já venham ok pessoal
estamos aqui outra vez agora estamos no
modo normal estávamos em mim agora um
dia vai ser uma dificuldade apenas pra
ver se eu consigo passar esta noite o
meia foi noite ele em cima da hora já
não tinha visto sequer
mas vamos lá pessoal agora que já possui
mais ou menos e um jogo eu vou ficar
aqui tento ao foxy alfredão o foco se
não fosse o drama por seu elevado de
tóquio fox fox neto anos ainda só por si
um frete colônia e e esses pronto até
agora ainda não vi que o zé do palhaço
ou é que o fred olhar que o fred maroto
ônibus milton mira o mais forte em volta
do sol a série está muito realista me
porque eles foram fazer isso no chão
este meu
eu não gosto é esta porque ele está aqui
transmissão junho - gosto está bom
não não está claro se foi sua cara do
boninho está muito realmente está muito
legal aqui avançou avançou não fosse
morar com ela foi embora abra a porta a
uma símbolos e isso nada tranqüilo está
tudo tranqüilo da arkham ataque lançou
uma só pedra operação na luz os costa
mental eu canto eu tô aqui para se auto
que olha com a porta é porque tá ali que
o canto e chutou no canto também
anunciou que em 15 anos com quem nos
relacionamos outra vez
qualquer piloto como exatamente o meu
lado e ouvir ouvir o avançado que houve
um ataque ou não eu ainda aqui mas não
sai daqui prática típica um bonitão
destruir ética já não não acredito
tranqüila o suíço
isso é isso mesmo isso é isto mesmo foi
da boca
embora de modo a bola e tentar a
tentativa de burla e estou quebrou nesta
semana
luxa por semana e aqui que é chique
ataque mês mas presta a um power acabou
aí o qual acabou outra vez não atentará
tentou power é não por favor não faça o
mal tem um amigo que eles podem pagar e
pelo meu resgatar bem vocês podem fazer
um negócio com ela e eu dava dinheiro tá
não precisam de matar a menina e isto
estuda oferecer dinheiro funciona sempre
não funciona temos tudo isso já acontece
no jockey
estamos incluindo agora qualquer pessoa
ao passarmos a dificuldade mídia por
isso se quiserem ver mais de jogo nem
nos comentários deixando o nosso leque
vosso apoio é muito importante se
quiserem que os jovens tinham ganho
outra ou em artes premem os comentários
com dar que quer ver ajudar o modo arda
e e só espero que vocês tenham gostado e
eu gostei muito da minha cueca também
estava carregada
deixe o seu punho fiquem bem e até a
próxima